traum jetzt hier nicht ganz sicher zu
rütteln doch mit drachen kriegen ja es
ist irgendwie hinkriegt glaube ich dir
genau unter mich kann ich nicht dass die
wand weg ich habe kein eises spitzhacke
man so du bist direkt neben mir jetzt
hier komm' raus die rap stehen war er
bleibt stehen sobald sich der name ist
alles richtig kraft über mir wegen
shader wegen shader aber hallo wir sind
wieder vereint
hier guck mal gute spitzhacke komm komm
ich zeig dir ganz ganz viele sachen sind
jeglichen eine bessere mannschaft pusht
sich der halbe ort gesehen genau am
besten warum ist ab und an gebe nach
oben um endlich weil eigentlich mehr als
vier folgen wollten jetzt eigentlich
nicht machen bevor der gast kommt aber
dann muss wenigstens schon so ein
grundriss von unserem hause da sein
auch gar nichts anbieten können ja
schreckt mich nicht so robens eisen ja
jetzt auch noch was ganz viele
wir nehmen so viel wie möglich was so
erstmal schnell geht mit ich bin fast
tot
brauche ich dafür echt nirgendwo mond
davon kann sich eine fackel wir machen
es extrem dunkel hier ist das sexy bei
mir ist das voll hell da liegt das an
einem shaker sache hier kannst du mir
ein paar vergeben weil ich habe keine
alter dann liegt es wirklich an der
stelle bei mir ist alles so was von
harry bei der shader macht halt da
dunkel und daher
ich werde shell einstellen noch mal ein
bisschen optimieren aber ob tief ein
gerade ist es so wie cheese kriegt jetzt
übrigens war ob die fein wenn man
spendeten umhang das gab es auch schon
länger ja aber das habe ich mir das
aufgefallen so was auch eine coole sache
da kannst du dich denkt
unterstützenswertes projekt da ständig
was für aber wenn jetzt wieder bei free
to play sachen wenn man sagt ja kommen
mir ist es wert dann aber da darf
natürlich die anderen auch kein nachteil
von herrsching da natürlich auch wieder
ja ok aber das war altes thema wir
wollen uns neues thema gab es noch 13
minuten hier
ach ja es gibt noch ein gutes free to
play spiel um das abzubringen
nämlich wie konnte ich das nur
unterschlagen ich weiß es nämlich nicht
wie es heißt hier heißt das was das
gekostet team fortress 2
ich glaube da kann man auch da kann man
auch sachen kaufen die ein besser machen
aber das ist irgendwie ich bin nicht
sicher glaubt dass es irgendwie gut
gelöst dass man das auch irgendwie so
erreichen kann oder sind sogar nur
sachen die ich glaube wenn ein solches
hat dann kann man die nur auf speziellen
servern
unglaublich oder irgendwie so um den
dreh man kann sich da das projekt an
sich ist eigentlich eine relativ gute
idee an sich aber ist es sehr
ausbaufähig muss man sagen
koller raus gehen jetzt gehen wir raus
wenn wir dass man mit ihr und versuchen
hier raus also ich will lediglich dann
beginnen wir beide mal am besten mit dem
grundriss von unseren häusern damit wir
irgendwann vor zwei jahren haben und ich
nicht noch sterbe damit war der erste
gas kommt das nächste folge auf jeden
fall einschalten du also nicht du
sondern sogar vorm fernseher genau stehe
ich hoffe es kommt dann darüber könnt
mir einmal reden aber ich würde sagen
wir sind ihr quatschen lieber bei themen
die ihr gesagt
das könnte als welche von euch
vielleicht in die kommentare schreiben
und zwar fernsehen youtube im fernsehen
ob sich das durchsetzen wird das youtube
shows werden dann kommen die weltweit
tätig ist ja rtl jetzt verrät euch das
gesagt nein
bundesweit ist das ganz andere natürlich
name allerdings eher als ob über
fernsehen in 20 jahren jetzt noch so
hart ist wie das heute ist er heute ist
es auch die sonne geht unter
wo wir gleich gar kein licht mehr haben
das ist echt beeilen um nach hause zu
kommen wir auf fast tot bin ich hoffe du
weißt ungefähr und schlagt mich nicht
weil ich bin etwas total.com mit ich
hoffe dass ich irgendwann müssen uns
unbedingt kompass und karte und sowas
bauen
und wenn mir scharfe sehen scharfen
mitnehmen also das echt also ich
verstehe warum schafe so selten sind
nämlich schon echt ein bisschen
unverständlich sind auf einer freien
fläche wir haben unendliches schweine
und klüger und keine schafe gar keine
schafe und wir möchten unendliche
hühnereis mal aufgefallen ich habe noch
kinder und da sind wir schon wieder
einem übermaß und überfluss aber ich war
noch eine große zwecken
es gibt fast dunkel muss immer steiler
optimieren aber wie gesagt ist auch eine
beta version des klassikers der sieht
der sieht klaus kallaus an vielen
stellen das wieder irgendwie so als viel
zu dunkel oder viel zu helfen
natürlich dann blöd ich hier so aus habe
ich schon mal war aber weder eine kiste
ich sehe dann ja gut da bin ich hier ich
baue jetzt erstmal hier so was blödes
drum rum und zwar mich in der erde
ich hoffe nur dass jetzt nicht auf
meiner insel dich nieder auf meiner
erhöhung nicht niedergelassen hast du
ich brauche ich erstmal in massa ich
sehe ich sehe wo ich bin sehr gut ich
stecke das erstmal mit fackeln ab so
leute bitte nicht meckern das ganze wird
noch besser viel besser ich eigentlich
viel zu wenig kabel sind ein du könntest
mal wenig ich habe auch wenig du
könntest mal wieder thema vorlesen die
nachdem in springe man ein bisschen
zuschauer user partizipation und so mir
ist gerade also erstmal von cz stern
fracht setzte ein thema eingefallen
waren haltlos
weil derweil bei windows 8 rauskommt und
so was hältst du davon war von windows 8
als überhaupt schon mal irgendwie damit
beschäftigt was wie das so ist
ich habe da gar keine ahnung von ich
habe gehört dass sein team wie total
einfach hier dann werden mit windows 8
aber ich finde apple ist das einfachste
betriebssystem was es gibt und ich werde
erstmal bei behinderten bleiben also
diese diese sachen so ja aber ich bei
apple ist doch eigentlich besser ist
immer so
wer ansichtssache na ja nein wenn das
für komplett ohne argumente einfach oder
irgendwie so des vega ich bin seit
einfacher weil es natürlich bei apple
ist blöd von der richtige sprung und
hahn bekommen vielleicht hunger nein das
haben wir dann wieder bei diesem apple
windows krieg wir wollen ja den über
windows 8 reden aber darüber kann ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen damit das
müsste ich jetzt mal passen da müsste
darüber sagen das ding ist dass es eine
komplett neue oberfläche hat kennt so
windows phone 7 wie das aussieht so mit
diesen teilen alltag in china gar nicht
aus opfer auf jeden fall ist windows 8
wird eine komplett andere oberfläche als
die bisherige windows schon ziemlich
radikaler schritt ist so abgestimmt dass
man es gleich auf
chemnitz und das gleich auf normalen pcs
so die oberfläche hat und da bin ich mir
nicht sicher ob das wirklich so eine
gute design entscheidung ist aber man
wird auch sehen mit der zeit
ob das ob sich das warten aber ist auch
das erste mal sonst immer so genau auf
windows vista nehme ich sofort auch wenn
alle gesagt damit nicht so gut windows 7
nämlich sofort damals am meisten sagt ja
alles okay aber jetzt ist das erste mal
ich werde erstmal bei windows 7 stecken
auch weil es halt jetzt beruflich jetzt
in anführungszeichen durch let's play
inhalt darauf angewiesen wenn das alles
läuft und ich das jetzt mit bundestag
etwas nicht läuft herum ärgern muss ich
erstmal windows 7 weiter benutzen bis
eine größere zahl von leuten -8 benutzt
und dann auch alles was ich weiß ist
alles so lange ich es kann werde ich
windows 7 nutzen solange nicht
irgendwann ist so ja dieses spiel das
bei anspruch jetzt aber 108 pass sondern
auch sowas nicht kommt dann werde ich
auf jeden fall 107 benutzen egal ob es
jetzt klappt oder nicht mit windows 8
ich werde auf jeden fall erstmal so
lange es geht windows 7 benutzen aber
auch dann wenn du gar nicht weiß wie es
ist sagt jetzt schon wieder
ja ich habe mich an windows 7 gewöhnt
ich weiß wie es ihr geht mit programm
lassen ja aber dass das finde ich nicht
so gut die leute also so wie du dann
jetzt dann nehme ich dich jetzt einfach
mal so als stereotyp
also ich war doch aus diesen weißem holz
ich mag das einfach also nägel
vielleicht aus den dunklen holz bauen
aber dass jemand mir die sache ist ich
finde so lange ein etwas nicht etwas
bewährt hat so lange es klappt sollte
man davon eigentlich auch nicht weggehen
never change a running system ja genau
das ist das deine einstellung der von
neuem
wenn etwas neues kommt sowie windows 8
jetzt im vergleich zu windows 7 und alle
halten das und sagen jetzt ist total
toll
von mir aus kann es sein ich werde
vielleicht mal antesten wenn es mir gut
gefällt ok werde ich da mal probieren
aber solange da das bei windows 7 immer
noch genauso gut läuft bleibe ich auf
prosieben
ich meine warum sollte ich zu windows 8
wechseln wenn er dann vielleicht ein
bisschen anderes design team 17 komme
ich genau so gut klappt wenn jetzt bei
108 gesagt wird ja doppelt so gut und
doppelt da so leicht und ganz ganz viele
shorties und alles mögliche keine ahnung
was da eine neue kommt wenn dann so was
kommt dann wäre ich denke ich auch mal
wechseln aber
aber wir waren wirklich bestätigt gut
ist also ich werde so früh wie möglich
wechseln wenn mir gesichert ist dass
alles läuft und so weit aber ich bin
einer der will immer das neueste haben
aus dem prinzip als neuestes hat es
darum habe ich auch ein galaxy nexus das
ist das alte handy weil er kriegt die
neuesten android update sofort ein neues
prinzip das neueste haben hallo entweder
das ist wieder so eine sache wenn du die
wahl hätte zwischen dem google nexus und
ein iphone zu gewinnen was willst du
immer zwei von vier nexus das ist nicht
dein ernst oder
natürlich sind meine und die sind
hardwaremäßig komplett ebenbürtig und
der rat wer aber von der bedienung her
eine bedienung her auch es halt android
und aber das neueste android 4.1 das als
ich es vielleicht noch nie benutzt dass
es kommt dass es komplett geil also da
hat er hat auch nichts von irgendwelchen
alten android handys von motorola oder
so gewöhnt ist weil die ja auch immer
noch ihre eigene oberfläche auf packen
beim google handys der original android
ist eine komische oberfläche darauf dass
war flüssig komplett alles ich finde
bedingung ist super und ist einfach da
ich als offen ist man fühlt sich beim
ipod immer eine beim iphone immer
eingeschränkt ist ja total also meine
grenzen meiner familie haben sie alle
bruder schwester ja alle echt alle voll
krass selbst meine mutter meine alten
iphone und ipod nano bei mir ist es auch
so dass wirklich jeder ein iphone hat da
kann man jetzt sagen aber das ist echt
verbreitet ist wenn einer aus der
familie nein aber das empfohlen weil es
einfach einfach einer bindung ist aber
so ein bisschen ahnung hat und ein
bisschen mehr als die standard sachen
machen möchte und so ein bisschen rum
frickel und immer das neueste und so
weiter so wie ich dann android
aber wenn man echt so ein techniker ist
und so wenig ahnung hat dann iphone ist
es klasse weise muss ein ganz bisschen
bedienung lernen und dann weiß wie alles
funktioniert ich interessiere mich für
technik und ich mach mit dem iphone
nicht nur app store spieler
david abrufen sondern dann damit auch
dann irgendwie weiß nicht ich verstehe
nicht was du unter mehr technik
verstehst aber ich bin nicht ich komme
beim iphone super klar und ich verstehe
nicht warum ich da als offene andere die
marke wechseln will ich denke dass die
meisten von ihnen aber einmal ich denke
dass die meisten zuschauer kein iphone
haben werden weil viele dann auch nach
dem preis urteilen glaube ich galaxy
nexus oder ein galaxy s3 kurz auch nicht
viel weniger als ein iphone
also das ist dann auch nicht nur der
preis sondern das entscheidet man sich
auch bewusst für ein android für ein
high end android gerät entscheidet man
sich bewusst und nicht als dienst gehen
bewusst weil man es einfach besser
findet es also nicht nur nicht nur
geschmackssache so gut ich mache das
lieber sondern halt einfach wenn man
durch geht ja gut dass und das bei
android gefällt mir besser oder das ist
wichtiger für mich andauernd nämlich
android ich werde mich mein hausbauer
zwingen wenn ich noch überlegt ziemlich
lange ich bin ja sonst immer so der typ
ich kann mich an ich habe auch erst mal
alle jetzt denn jetzt wohl erstmal den
teller teller
ich habe erstmal mich um den teller
gekümmert achtet er erstmal der keller
keller keller ist ja riesig die aufnahme
zweieinhalb minuten vorbei dann müssen
weil dabei ein internet wächst und dann
wird das nächste mal es aller
voraussicht nach der erste gast dabei
sein
ja nicht nur aus sondern auf jeden fall
hat natürlich immer was dazwischen
kommen dass eine folge kommen aber es
wird auf jeden fall dann auf jeden fall
immer ein gast ab jetzt dabei sein
ihr werdet ihr sehen welche gesehen
einer allein kann immer sein das heißt
dass man dann aufnehmen will und dann
kann der typ dann noch nicht wegen der
krankheit oder so und dann kann es sein
dass irgend so lange keine folge bekommt
und dann sagen wir das ganz kurz oder
sachwerte zu erfahren bei facebook oder
über all das ist jetzt dann auch mit der
der gute faktor das den und ich dass
beide aufnehmen ist auf jeden fall immer
und in der video antwort bzw wenn ihr
das bei den akku bei mir dann verlinkt
da findet ihr immer die links zu
facebook und so weiter da werden wir das
dann alles schon sagen falls da was
dazwischen kommt richtig also irgendwas
ist dann wird es wird immer bei facebook
stehen aber an sich können darauf
vertrauen dass regeln folgen regelmäßig
wie wir sagen immer komm und zwar immer
mit
ist das jetzt hier die ersten vier
folgen dass wir ein bisschen was
aufbauen wenn der gast kommt dass wir
schon irgendwas haben und ich komplett
alleine herumstehen und wir sehen dass
wir gäste wir haben gäste vorstellen
könnte wie gesagt in die kommentare
schreiben
und dann sagen wir eigentlich an dieser
stelle schon fast noch nicht wir haben
auch zwei minuten zwei minuten auch
wieder positiv detail
ich möchte nicht aufhören die
mitarbeiter bauen es geht jetzt weiter
dranbleiben
das ist eine rein interne gleich weg ja
mein internet ist elf minuten weg aber
dann werde ich passe mich kannten karten
karten ihm rangieren allerdings de ag
das filmmaterial das läuft auch in so
einem band von dem projektor direkt raus
neben seinem schreibtisch und hörte
seine aufnahme von katja thater wenn ihr
euch immer gewundert was es ist das ist
die aufnahme die kommt hierher scanner
und danach weil sich mit der schere an
schnell das weg und da komme ich einer
von fünf metern
muss man da natürlich umwandeln und um
wenn ich also ich hab das dann einfach
japan converter nennt man toaster steht
man einfach die spur ein die ich
aufgenommen habe und dann kriegt man den
mp4 datei unten raus die ist dann
natürlich virtuell das sieht dann immer
ein bisschen als wenn ich dann mit einer
luft mit luft quasi in der hand rumlaufe
die zauber ich dann meinen pc rein und
dann habe ich dann video und dann
bekommt das heiße jupiter youtube dann
fliegen wir eben noch nach los angeles
und geben das den und dann ja und so ist
quasi wie wir aufnehmen
richtig gute juli nach mountain view zum
quartier wo war das nochmal genau das
war das signal der unia
alles ist also facebook diese ja immer
am arsch der welt
die sind auch da nein die haben ihr
haupt nämlich er den hauptsitz haben sie
da aber die haben auch ein gebäude wohl
der mark zuckerberg auch oft mal abhängt
und zwar ist das irgendwo am strand auf
hawaii oder so um den dreh
das mag sein woher genau darum geht aber
das hauptquartier ist mit sicherheit
auch im slocan dass ich das alles ist
müssen die medien firmen
die internetindustrie google ist gut das
war's für diese folge die anderen ja
schließlich und eine tür habe und zwei
mauern und tastatur und hat im keller
jetzt kommt sowas courier schauen wir
uns einmal direkt im keller beide an den
weg weg der staat kann zwar sprechen
kommt ich schlag dich nicht mehr neu
gebaut gibt auch schon also gut sieht
schon älter so geschmackssache ich finde
und dann in einem gast also bis dahin
einem jahr online ist und von der today
show
bis zum nächsten mal kommentare nicht
vergessen bewerten nicht vergessen wenn
es gute daum hoven schlechter darunter
und so weiter und so fort